for the tampa bay devil rays this
afternoon it will be right-hander luis
patino making his 10th start of the
season the record 2-3 era of 4.73
and a broken bad ground ball for lau in
second so he comes back to get hernandez
swing and a miss two curveballs in that
sequence put away the lefty and some
good early signs here from
coutinho to pitch in on him and he pops
it into shallow right arose arena toward
the line is there
fastball then takes care of him in it
michael's grinding through
eight and six 4.48 era this guy is two
wins away from 100.
that's a sinker at the bottom of the
zone and a rosarina does not like it
it's a good pitch it's exactly where he
wanted it cuts the bottom of half of
that box
and there's a base head off keikal
he got it to the right of abreu
will cruise with those six home runs off
kykel
that's his 19th career hit now at 58
advance against the lefty
right there change up bottom of the zone
and look meadows doesn't like it but
those boats were strikes i believe yandy
diaz
chops it towards short gonna be to the
left to mendic and through into center
crews will advance to second
and diaz going after the first pitch and
the rays have first and second here's
wander franco
ground ball that takes a big hop and
bounces over makata into foul territory
rates are going to get a run
cruise crosses the plate diaz goes to
third and that's a double for bronco
dwayne the ball bounced right off the
top of third base
that's where the bad hop came from you
talk about a fortunate bounce for the
raise and two men in scoring position
for brandon lau
now a shot off the bat of brandon lau
well tagged and that's gonna
short hop the wall
two more runs will score diaz followed
by bronco on the double by loud well
here it is like we said you've got to
see some pitches elevated and that's
what brandon lau got right there
in the air to left
and goodwin in left center makes the
catch for round number three tough start
three nothing after one
mike zenino set to lead off
and ball four kaiko loses cenino here's
joey wendell ground ball headed toward
the middle through into center field a
dive by mendix as he comes up short
julino to second on the base hit by
wendell and nelson cruz the single in a
run scored in the first bats again here
in the second inning
that's a one hopper
backhanded by hernandez thrown her first
in time that's going to get zanino home
send wendell over to third and the rays
now lead four to nothing and sebby
zavala will bat here in the third
semi zavala gives this one a ride and
this is absolutely demolished the socks
are on the board
sebby does it again it's four to one
big swing by sevi right here did not
miss that ball
as soon as that ball left the bat i knew
that one was gone you could hear the
crack of the bat all the way up in
chicago hit it a mile in the air
104 off the bat
400 feet man the power has really shown
up for sevi zavala but here's zanino
kaikal got ahead of him in the count in
the second inning and then wound up
walking out
into left-center field cutting across
goodwin going to be over his head and
bounce away from him to the deep part of
the park zenino around second turning on
the afterburners going for three triple
for torino
mike genito
a triple
goodwin's got to make this catch this
ball right here watch goodwin's route
this is a ball off the end of the bat
and he just completely takes a shallow
route and allows that ball to get over
his head and once it does look at the
big guy go
yes sir
here's wendell and the infield's going
to move
in oh a ground ball he reaches out
wendell and gets it through the middle
and zanino trots home
and the rays pick up their fifth run of
the day move along to the fifth race
with a 5-1 lead
oh there's a strike dropped that
fastball down
just above the knees got him looking
dick swings and sends a fly ball into
left
caught by meadows
and a swing and a miss
three fastballs takes care of them one
two three
yeah that will bring up wander franco
ground ball toward the hole
stop by mendick but the throw will not
arrive in time
and franco has his second hit of the day
so rudder at first two away here's
manuel margot who is twice fly to center
fly ball toward the gap in left center
field one hopping the wall
broncos hitting third linares will wave
him home and he's going to score
he came in head first there was no play
the throat cut off by abreu so the rays
pick up their sixth run
wander right there sensing he's gonna be
able to score let's take a look
oh yeah it was a little bit of uh
do you remember when randy arose in see
how those hands come back and then all
of a sudden you face plan that's what
happened with randy rosarina out at
second base watch his arms
they get caught back up and then all of
a sudden there goes the face
nobody on coutinho
that falls rocked to left field by abreu
jose chugging for second he's got a two
out double he has half the sox hits in
the ball game they get a man in a
scoring position two out for eloa
jimenez this to center field
jose's around third he's on his way home
and the socks make it six to two eloy
jimenez at rbi
and the socks are within four that's all
it takes you just gotta scratch one here
one one in the seventh
find a way to get back in this game give
yourself a chance
hernandez who has one stolen base needs
it first there's goodwin good one over
three
brian goodwin into center field phillips
is back he's at the track he's twisting
in the wind and it's off the wall
hernandez into third goodwin a double
phillips looked like he got his foot
stuck at one point
he was a wind sock out there in center
field the socks are in business second
and third nobody out and this isn't
important at bat for abreu
abreu in the air to right margot is
underneath he makes the catch
hernandez is on his way home the throw
into third is late on goodwin who does
get that extra base it's six to three
now with one out in the eighth column
mccube
he has been really good and he has not
given up a run since when
may the 24th may the 24th
and it is a slider to third base
wendell's gonna go on to first so eloy
gets the rbi it's five to three on the
ground out and six to four on the
scoreboard
here's manuel margot
he drives it into deep let's center
field that ball hands great carry will
one hop the wall and bounce over the
wall to the deepest part of the park
that will get loud home
on a double driven by margot
his second double of the game and his
second run ban it in it's 7-4
little number third base side mcconnell
is going to have to go to first and that
gets the job done
well he didn't have to drive it through
the infield
just that little number
and margot scores and the reigns again
lead by four eight more
so as we go to the ninth inning raise
right now holding on to an eight to four
lead and a lighter into center that's
going to be caught by phillips
and the razor winners
one two three in the ninth inning at the
rays defeat the white sox eight to four